sí buenas tardes se esperaba que en esta
reunión extraordinaria de los líderes
del g-7 recordemos los países más ricos
del mundo sin china y se en rusia se
pudiera persuadir al presidente joe
biden para que extendiera más allá del
31 de agosto que es la fecha límite para
la retirada de las tropas americanas de
territorio afgano para que pudiera
permitirse que más personas pudieran
dejar afganistán y entonces ya se ha
confirmado por parte de oficiales de
eeuu que no se dará esa extensión la
verdad era que era muy difícil y el
ánimo dentro de los aliados el reino
unido- como el presidente de este eje 7
en este año ya lo había dicho el
ministro de defensa que era poco
probable que se diera esa extensión
porque además tendría que ser aceptada
por el talibán que ha dicho en una
entrevista con sky news uno de sus
voceros que esa fecha de retirada el 31
de agosto es una línea roja y que si las
tropas occidentales se mantenían en
terreno
y habría consecuencias lo cierto es que
estos países del g7 los líderes han
firmado una declaración en la que le
piden al talibán permitir la evacuación
de todas las personas que quieran salir
del país más allá del 31 de agosto que
es en una semana también han acordado
una hoja de ruta para un posible
gobierno del talibán que incluye el
respeto por los derechos humanos
estándares de respeto por el derecho de
las niñas y de las mujeres a seguir
educándose no albergar organizaciones
terroristas como isis y también como al
qaeda y por supuesto dar garantías a
todos los ciudadanos que van a permitir
tener sus derechos que han conquistado
en los últimos 20 años luisa una
pregunta que surge porque el reino unido
no puede mantenerse en kabul sin la
autorización o mejor dicho sin el apoyo
de eeuu
porque eeuu tiene en este momento el
control del aeropuerto de kabul no solo
la maneja el dispositivo enorme de
seguridad con las tropas británicas sino
además el espacio aéreo que aviones
salen y que aviones aterrizan así que
por ello es fundamental pero además
tiene toda la logística militar y todo
el personal se cree que tiene seis mil
personas en terreno así que sin este
apoyo no puede ser posible para ningún
país como el reino unido- incluso lo tan
poderse mantener en terreno afgano más
allá de la fecha de retirada que haya
sido confirmada el 31 de agosto es decir
en una semana hemos consultado algunos
expertos y coinciden en que aunque el
reino unido- quisiera no podría
permanecer en terreno afgano si eeuu se
retira